- All right, let's wrap up
this hour with one more dose
of the Christmas spirit,
this is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd applauding)
So usually when you think of Santa,
you envision the plump rosy cheeks,
a bushy long silver beard,
and that sort of rotund
physique, right? Well,
there's a new Santa in town,
and he's a straight up
silver fox people. (laughs)
This Toronto man is known
as the Fashion Santa's,
with his chiseled face and slick beard,
people all over North
America are lining up
to take selfies with him,
including Justin Bieber.
Let's get Paul, the
Fashion Santa on the line,
what's up, man?
(crowd applauds)
- (Paul laughing) Hey, hey.
- I mean, it's like Santa
Claus had a true makeover.
It was like Merry Christmas. (laughs)
- Happy holidays.
- Oh, I love that.
So how did you become
known as the Fashion Santa,
other than just looking like you?
- First I wanna say thank you
for having me on your show,
I'm a big big fan, and I've
been following you forever,
and, thank you so much.
- Oh, thank you, that
was so kind, thank you.
(crowd applauds)
Well I have to ask, like how,
how did this come about,
the Fashion Santa thing?
- Okay, so I was a model in New
York city for about 15 years
and sadly my mother got
diagnosed with cancer,
unfortunately she passed
away, and in my grief,
I kind of went to sleep for a year,
didn't shave, that's her, Dona Mason.
Didn't shave, and woke
up and just decided like,
I look like a Claus, and I
was in the fashion business,
and, put it together, made a
pitch to a couple of retailers,
the mall in Toronto picked it
up and, in 2015 we went viral.
We had initiatives that for every
selfie taking with Fashion Santa,
a dollar was donated
to the local hospital.
- Wow!
- I think we raised about
$20,000 that season.
And it's continued, now I
have four holiday cards,
that all the proceeds go to
a children's miracle network
in the US, and a sick
kids hospital in Canada.
So, yeah, that's where it
came from so, that's it.
- I love the artwork as well,
that was so cool, the artwork.
- Yeah, that's, I
collaborated with an artists
from Montreal, Steve Lapeer,
and we did this over like, Instagram.
Because of COVID, we just
kinda designed these cards,
just by messaging, or over like Instagram,
which is incredible.
- Oh, that's incredible.
Well, thank you so much Fashion Santa.
(crowd applauds)
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(chuckles) Love that photo.
And that's not all, our
season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you my man,
so they're gonna give you
$1,000, how's that sound?
(crowd applauds)
- Wow! Oh my God! That's
amazing, that's amazing.
Thank you, thank you so much.
- I know, and at some point,
I want a picture with Fashion
Santa, is all I'm saying.
- Oh, yes, I definitely
would want a photo with you,
are you kidding?
- Okay, well, it's recorded
now, we have it on film so,
we're gonna make it happen.
- Thank you so much for joining us today.